Trump would create free Freedom focused
online American Academy as president and
he'd make the woke IVs pay for it it
will be strictly non-political and there
will be no wokeness or jihadism allowed
I see a lot of people cheering for this
but I'm going to be completely honest
this is a stupid idea sorry it just is
uh let me play the video recent weeks
Americans have been horrified to see
students and faculty at Harvard and
other once respected universities
expressing support for the Savages and
jihadists who attacked Israel we spend
more money on higher education than any
other country and yet they're turning
our students into Communists and
terrorists and sympathizers of many many
different dimensions we can't let this
happen it's time to offer something
dramatically different
under the plan I'm announcing today we
will take the billions and billions of
dollars that we will collect by taxing
fining and suing excessively large
private university endowments and we
will then use that money to endow a new
institution called the American Academy
its Mission will be to make a truly
world-class education available to every
American free of charge and do it
without adding a single dime to the
federal debt this institution will
gather an entire universe of the highest
quality educational content covering the
full spectrum of human Knowledge and
Skills and make that material available
to every American citizen online for
free whether you want lectures or
ancient histories or an introduction to
financial accounting or training in a
skilled trade the goal will be to
deliver it and get it done properly
using study groups mentors indust
Partnerships and the latest breakthrough
in Computing this will be a truly top
tier education option for the people it
will be strictly non-political and there
will be no wokeness or jihadism allowed
none of that's going to be allowed most
importantly the American Academy will
compete directly with the existing and
very costly 4-year University system by
granting students degree credentials
that the US government and all federal
contractors will henceforth recognize
the academy will award the full and
complete equivalent of a bachelor's
degree in addition to help the 40
million Americans who have some college
education but no degree the American
Academy will grant credit for past
coursework at Legacy institutions and
give you the chance to complete your
education at the American Academy for
free and much more quickly than is now
possible or available this will will be
a revolution in higher education and
will provide life-changing opportunities
for tens of millions of our citizens
enjoy it learn from it and thank you I
just want I just want to say real quick
the most important thing here is room
tone guys when you're shooting these
videos you need to record about 30
seconds of what's called room tone
silence so that you can mask the jump
Cuts but anyway what were you saying is
this like a a GED but for a bachelor's
degree instead of high school diploma
and I think look I can respect the
colleges are garbage they're making kids
Communists but the government making
another program is not the solution yeah
this is the this is the same dilemma you
had when you were talking about the
Central Bank digital currencies except
with education it's the same exact thing
oh the government's going to swoop and
crate Government College for you don't
worry Trump says it won't be woke no way
he'll get out of office and then some
crackpot woke person will bang the gavl
and it'll turn to woke you and then the
government's funded it it can never die
can never go away no he likes to say
that everything woke turns to but
but really it's everything the
government touches turns to it's
also the government touches the puts the
woke in it yeah he's saying you know I
want people to have opportunities to get
whatever but why don't we just stop
giving out student loans I feel like
that's the thing that I'm more
interested in seeing right I mean there
are tons to college we'll stop
subsidizing the whole system entirely it
doesn't it doesn't make you could solve
a lot of issues that way in fact you
could make College affordable I do love
how he came out with his own rightwing
version of free college for all though
that's hilarious and if and if he fails
at president will definitely see the ads
on Facebook where he's like you know
give us your email address and we'll
send you an email subid do this for free
subsidizing college was one of the
biggest mistakes this our society ever
made yes because what happens now is
young person says oh I can get aone to
go to college I'll learn uh I'll take
something I don't even know most kids
don't even know what their Major's going
to be I don't even know what my major is
going to be then why are you going so
they go thinking they're going to get a
job that kid that that 17-year-old I say
kid because they're 17 they're planning
College they turn 18 they go to college
if they just went and got a job working
at their like local with a handyman true
Lo local local mechanic engineer
electrician they said I'm just going to
do go for work heating and air
conditioning they'd learn real skills
that translate they'd have an actual job
and then they can figure things out as
they're getting older or they can work
work these skills and maybe I don't know
being an electrician is a great skill to
have and they could have learned that
they didn't have to go to college they
go to trade school or something instead
they graduate four years later and go
oops you know what's a better idea than
going to Trump's uh America School
is just running for your local
Schoolboard and changing the school
district in your own in your own
locality literally it's it's going to be
just as easy if you could change
everything if they never subsidized
College young people would not have gone
and wasted their time generating debt
and then learning nothing there there
are PE so what happens is uh I read this
great article this is when I was a kid
they said you need an IQ of at least 110
to go to college and the problem is
subsidized universities is telling
everyone of any capability to go to
college you end up with people who are
not bright enough who can't understand
the material I think we were talking
about the other day like college was
supposed to be you sat down and
experimented and worked with like-minded
individ individuals and you wrote a
thesis you were saying this and now it's
jened now it's like here's your homework
come back you know it's like being in
high school I mean and this is also
different than let's say like the
British system right like in the
equivalency of high school in England
you are already narrowing down what you
want to study in America we keep
students taking everything for as long
as possible and now that basically lasts
until they you know if you enroll in
college at 18 that's the first two years
of college so when you're 20 you are
still taking General classes as instead
of specializing in a skill yeah but the
longer you're in the more money you owe
the government exactly I mean that's the
thing about subsidizing is that you were
able to say to colleges name your price
and we will write a blank check and we
will force them to agree to take it
that's crazy that also means that
there's no uh incentive for colleges to
say hey we're going to make this quick
and efficient for you I mean there are
schools that will say oh well we're
revamping our general Ed criteria so
actually you can't graduate unless you
take you know summer courses which cost
additional money or you you spend an
extra year here I mean they're trying to
make it last as long as possible because
they don't care that you're going into
debt and in fact while I was sitting
here my college called me to try and get
a donation this is just you know that
you will always be a meal ticket for
them and I I think it's sad because
there are probably professors who are
really dedicated to things that they're
interested in you know there are
students who are genuinely interested in
learning it's the administration well
and also if we did not have college
would you have you know people who spend
money buying tickets to lectures instead
like right now we trap all of learning
in college when it doesn't have to be
that way you got KH Academy you can do
all kinds of things I mean you can get
free lectures online as it is I don't
know why we need American Academy except
for the fact that now they're saying you
could potentially get the equivalency of
a GED but for your bachelor's so if you
gotten some college somewhere but also
to what end if you've been able to find
a good job after having left College why
would you then go back and get a degree
except for like I guess wanting to seem
sort of elite and good I don't really
get what the benefit of this is uh I
like that he said they would rush you
could rush through so kids that are
really smart and they want to work 10
hours a day can get their degree in a
year you can do that with dual
enrollment programs while you're in high
school I mean you can get I've known
kids who graduate high school with their
AA degree if they're getting dual
enrollment during college CR like
through their local Community College
there are tons of ways to go through
college faster I think we don't talk
about them because ultimately everyone
wants you on this pipeline where you go
into Deb yeah yeah but you're talking
about things that don't need college for
things where you need to get a degree
like being a doctor for instance you're
not going to do it online you have to go
and do medical practice and and rounds
you have to learn how to actually save
lives you should be able to do it online
though medical work yeah sure you
because uh you got to learn how to tie
AR would you go to a doctor that got his
his education online no of course not of
course not nobody would this is the
information age we know if we know where
somebody went schol so you think the
average person would then it's it's the
responsibility of the individual to
check onto the the the practice and I
don't disagree you could learn a lot of
the information um the book information
online but then you do need to go
practice Labs I had a friend in high
school who put himself through college
while uh working as a paramedic all four
years and or first TR I can't remember
an EMT um if he wanted to be a doctor
shouldn't he automatically get real
world credit like it he doesn't he
shouldn't have to take certain classes
because he has the practical skills I
get that eventually maybe he has to go
to Medical a big difference between an
EMT and a Doctor by the way but like at
the same time she's had more hands-on
experience than any kid who anyone who
just took a biolog class right there
should be some recognition of real world
skill I think if you get if you're if
you're good at it and it took you two
years to become an expert doctor I'd
rather have you than a guy who's 12
years in school and doesn't know what
he's doing I really don't care about how
long it takes all these I mean that's
why there are like standardized tests
that all of them go through to say yes I
am now a good doctor I am qualified to
be a good doctor when I say I want the
government out of Education I don't just
mean my kids education I mean all
education entirely that's why I'm like
never should have been involved in
education Trump saying free University
is is exactly what he's trying to do
it's terrible but there's something like
you don't want one School teaching that
2 plus 2 equals 5 and another school
teaching that it equals four you got to
have some government over site because
then everyone will be would you put your
kid in the school that teaches 2 plus 2
equals 5 if there I wouldn't but if my
parents thought it equal five they
probably would have put me in that
school yeah well and so we have a
federal government that's like no we're
going to have some standardization it's
terrible kids aren't standardized at all
well some of it like you ever you ever
been around children yeah they're all
different everyone but if they were
being taught that words meant different
things that would be a big problem so we
need some standardization otherwise we'd
go to war we need that standardization
only because children uh parents have
become entirely disinterested with their
children's education that's the only
problem they're disinterested in their
kids yeah enti also if a private school
is wanted to tweak kids and there was no
government oversight they could like
make little terrorists or make people
think the wrong thing slightly the
government is doing this now in a bunch
of States well that's a problem but the
government is the biggest purveyor of
what you're talking about I think the
government's too involved but I don't
think no government in education no
government in education at all at all
100% as there used to be no there used
to be no government in education and
kids could go to their local schools
they could go to any school they wanted
to they learned all the all the things
that helped build this country without
the government n State telling them what
they had to do in education what year oh
I don't know the federal government got
involved in the 70s but the states have
been involved for quite some time but
prior to that the state governments
weren't involved in education you know
when they started
I80 that's the department
of but there there's been State
involvement in schools much longer than
that but not that much longer than that
1867 was the Office of Education yeah
yeah that's probably because the Civil
War happened and they were like we can't
let that happen again we need to teach
these people the same
thing I don't know I think just
ultimately the government doesn't want
you to have uh an independent life
outside of its purview right and so
maybe it was a civil war But ultimately
as soon as they started saying hey it
turns out we can have a say in your
domestic life if we mandate that your
children go to school right there there
has always been an a tendency toward
creeping reach into influence and I
think the issue is ultimately that the
government doesn't know better than
parents I could get the argument that
you want to say that information is
standardized but knowing that 2 plus 2
equals 4 is basic logic I mean that's
irrefutable I live in Iowa it's like one
of the the most free education states in
the country I mean as far as uh uh
education Freedom goes you you can
homeschool your children and you don't
have to tell the government anything at
all you can just petition your local
school district when they're 18 and you
think they've gone far enough to get
them their diploma so like do you think
the government should come in and tell
us we can't do we can't homeschool our
kids anymore the way that we are I don't
know it depends on what you're teaching
them I guess why because if you're
teaching them that killing is good
that's a big problem murder is good that
would be a big problem murder murder is
illegal the my kids kill somebody
they're going to get they're going to
get arrested that's already illegal but
if like a state was teaching their kids
like it's okay to steal this like there
are La you just set a state though
that's a that's a government yeah if
there were children within a state all
being self- schooled to think that
things that were legal or legal like you
need some some oversight of of some
structure we don't have any and I will
at all and everybody's just fine some of
the only compelling argument I've ever
heard for having you know minimal inv
government involvement with
homeschooling and because you know Iowa
doesn't have any but some states have
more than others so you can look these
up online they'll be you know blogs or
whatever that rate it like New York
state has high regulation it's very
difficult to homeschool in New York uh
West Virginia is sort of middle tier and
one of the things that comes up when you
regulate with homeschooling or when you
enroll in homeschooling is some states
require you to do a certain number of
and standardized tests to prove that
your kid is learning or meeting certain
criteria or you have to submit your
curriculum some some state governments
require that I contend that putting the
the government into education has had a
huge huge only time I've ever heard
anyone make a compelling arum was this
one social worker who said the thing is
I just wouldn't want a student to not be
enrolled in any school and for us who
never know what happened to them and I
find that interesting because they're
making a direct uh like child welfare
argument right like if if a kid is in a
you know domestically violent home if
they just get lifted out of the system
if they never go to school you wonder
what happened when you do hear cases
like that but to me that speaks the fact
that we don't have strong communities
around them that would let children just
fall off the map yep thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net for uncensored
membersonly shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time